welcome everyone to another episode of
LED live we're excited to be with you at
once again this week and as many times
before we are joined with a guest this
time a familiar one our brother Mike
shrie who has joined us a couple of
times before it's always a joy to be
here thank you for being here Mike Mike
has some experience in many things uh
yoga being one of them of course he was
in a time in history where there was the
the hippie movement happening so he
knows a little bit about that a little
bit a little bit but Mike is also a
minister and so he has familiarity with
the Bible and we're happy to have him he
has come out with a new book which I'm
going to show you just briefly this is
called the beliefs of the Catholic
Church 25 questions comparing doctrines
P practices and traditions of scripture
with scripture yeah with script or to
scripture I'm sorry and Mike has some
experience here too because once upon a
time you were I was an alter boy I was
raised Catholic uh in fact I've got some
pictures I'll show in just a moment okay
so he's not just coming at this from a
uh a place of inexperience he's coming
with knowledge and he's been there done
that also we have an unfamiliar face
this is Aubrey and Aubrey is a new
member of our team so we're welcoming
Aubrey we hope that you will all welcome
her too type it in the comments welcome
Aubrey thank you and so she'll be a face
that you see on some of our future
program so we're happy to have Aubrey
here joining with us as well and denique
and denique of course denque is a is a
you know an oldie but goodie by now
right I'm the little light veteran
little light veteran yeah she's been
with us for several several years on and
off so tell us a little bit
about um your involvement in Catholicism
like were you raised Catholic yes in
fact let me show you of course this is
the title of our talk comparing
Catholicism to biblical Christianity
which I believe is very important yeah
and I have a couple of pictures here
that's me when I received first
communion and that was a real pivotal
day for me it was a sacred day for me I
felt like it was a real turning point
you know at first thought when I see
that picture if I didn't know any better
I'm I'm looking at it saying why do they
all have cell phones in their hands oh
no even though they're little books it
looks about the size you know and you
think of today's generation anyway it
just kind of looked that way initially
so so what is first communion well cuz I
think I I I I took like a communion
class when I was younger we might get
into it more deeply in a little while
but communion in the Catholic church is
really the center point of what they do
every Sunday you go to mass where
communion is celebrated and they believe
that it's literally the body and blood
and life and Divinity of the Lord Jesus
and they call it
transubstantiation right which is
controversial Doctrine and and something
that most Protestant groups if not all
Protestant groups I'm not aware of any
that believe to that degree and and they
don't allow you in Catholicism to do it
as a younger child you have to go
through certain classes to prepare you
and so you comprehend what you're doing
which in a sense I appreciate because to
them any kind of involvement like that
is something that should not be taken
lightly right and Christianity should
not be taken lightly so if there's one
thing I appreciate about Catholics it's
the fact that they really value as
sacred the things that they do whether I
agree with all of them or not they do
have a sacred respect for the things of
God and let me say right at the
beginning too that uh I went to prial
school did either of you ever go to
oh oh is this just Catholic School the
nuns taught oh no I I I I was sprinkled
as a baby my grandparents were catholic
are Catholic and um I did the class but
it's funny cuz I was so young I don't
remember much of it so when you said
that I was like what's that is that the
thing I did but I was given a rosary my
grandma taught the class and I
participated in the communion where you
don't get any of the wine or grape juice
you just get the what do you call the
little Brett the host the host so I got
the host
and then if at some point when I was
really young still my parents stopped
attending Catholic church so I don't
remember much of it but yeah but anyway
the the thing I
appreciate very much is e even though I
never found the Lord I never experienced
a personal relationship with Jesus as a
Catholic they laid a foundation for me
that was valuable where from my early
days onward I had this knowledge of
Jesus being who he was the son of God
God manifested In the Flesh and also his
sinless life virgin birth sinless life
his death on the cross for the sins of
humanity his resurrection praise God and
His Ascension into heaven which are
basic things that were very important
foundationally for me in life later on I
experienced the reality of it that
really trans transformed my life
radically and that's what I desire for
all Catholics because many of them are
very genuine very authentic absolutely
lovers of God and they believe in the
Bible and so we have a lot of common
ground and and here let me show you a
picture of me as an alter boy oh wow I'm
the one with the light around me that's
not a
Halo but uh anyway I served under father
father bidle and incidentally father
bidd was just one of the most kind and
gentle and God-fearing people I think
I've ever met I never served as an altar
boy under any priests that were coercive
and and immoral and that's a tragedy
when it happens in any church it's not
just the Catholic Church there's been
immorality scandals and every church but
he was a real role model for me
character-wise
and I wish I had been able to get back
in touch with him after I was born again
but uh now the nuns that taught us in
grave school they were just some of the
uh most self-sacrificing people I've
ever met but I've often said uh well I
mean to live in a Convent or to uh live
a celibate life you've got to have an
enormous amount of dedication to make
that kind of deol so so I do respect
that part I do respect the individual
personal commitment that those people
have made in order to serve God as they
thought was correct and to serve people
now some of the nuns could be really
fierce in school though but I don't
blame them if you have a a class with a
100 unruly kids or 50 unruly kids you
might get a little bit
Frid I'd be Beyond afraid probably now
this is a just a picture of the book
that you mentioned a little bit larg
larger picture and that's what our talk
is going to be based on but I thought
one of the first things that we should
talk about is the Born Again experience
since uh since Jesus made that an
emphasis that's a pivotal and a good
place to start is right here where Jesus
said most assuredly I say to you unless
one is born of water and of the spirit
he cannot enter the kingdom of God and
that which is born of the flesh is flesh
and that which is born of the spirit
spirit is Spirit do not Marvel that I
said unto you and the next uh line is
you must be born again all right well
Catholicism teaches that happens with
infant baptism Catholics believe when
that little baby is sprinkled five major
things happen let me go through it
number one that child is born again
number two that child is filled with
God's spirit number three original sin
is removed wait so the the baby sin is
that what they mean well that's
inherited that's that's not committed
sin that's contracted sin like from the
previous generation just the fact that
we live in sin it's a particular
Doctrine that's that's uh in very
emphasized in Catholicism it's called
Original Sin and and they have a little
bit different take on it but I see it as
the lower nature the Fallen nature and
the state of separation from God that
were all born into by virtue of of
inheriting that status from Adam and Eve
but they say original sin is removed
from the child when it's sprinkled so
Catholic children should be like the
most wonderful saintly children in the
world but you can ask the nuns that
dealt with us in parochial school
they'll say nah NADA no uh and then
number four they believe that child
receives the gift of eternal life at
that point and number five that child
becomes a member of the church and of
course that means the Catholic church
and also six and seven they believe that
child is positioned in Christ and
becomes a new
creation which I
believe is absolutely false all seven
points MH because well the best way to
explain it would be to go to the bibl
biblical example when Peter preached in
Acts chapter 2 on the day of Pentecost
he told the crowd that gathered repent
and be
baptized every one of you in the name of
Jesus Christ for the remission of sins
and you shall receive the gift of the
Holy Spirit right that's right so he
made it a prerequisite for repentance to
come first a little baby can't repent
that's right has no capacity for that
when
Phillip was about to baptize or
witnessed when when Philip witnessed to
the Ethiopian unit you remember that in
the book of
Acts and he convinced him wasn't that a
Divine moment when he jumped on that
Chariot can you imagine the shock on the
look the look on the face of the unic
but anyway uh he said to Philip after he
witnessed to him and explained how
Isaiah 53 was Messianic and it foretold
what Jesus would go through on the cross
they happen to be near some body of
water and he said see here is water what
does hinder me to be baptized watch what
Philip said if you believe with all your
heart then you can be baptized so he
would have withheld baptism from him if
he was not genuinely full of Faith the
point of baptism isn't to make uh wet
pagans right right mhm it's it's and
I've met a lot of them yeah I mean you
can put somebody in the water and it
doesn't mean that heart conversion has
happened absolutely and that is really
you know the prerequisite that you're
talking about is that heart conversion
experience and the other is is more of a
of a confirmation or a sign that that
has happened so but anybody can be you
can dunk anybody in the water it doesn't
make him Christian right right yeah
absolutely and fact I I explain it this
way that the substance is always more
important than the Shadow and there are
many things in Scripture that are
foreshadowings or symbolic
representations of another thing that is
far more important in its reality for
instance the Passover supper that Jews
still celebrate every
Passover and they eat the meat of a lamb
in that supper is representative
symbolically of the Lamb of God being
slain for us well that's the substance
and that's infinitely more important
than the shadow of a dinner where you
eat some lamb meat and some other things
and in like manner water baptism
represents symbolically being buried
with Christ abely you know that Ren
again yeah and risen again when you come
up out of the water you die to S and you
choose to lay because Paul talks about I
will make you a or God makes you a new
creature you know when you're born again
so it's a representative of dying to
self in your old life of sin not that
you will never sin again but choosing to
have the Holy Spirit Come into you
accepting Jesus he can help you overcome
that sin absolutely I think what's what
could be helpful and you're probably
going to get to this so I don't want to
jump ahead of you necessarily but I'm
looking at this slide I see this list I
see it applied to B to baptism for
infants and you know especially for
those that don't understand I think a
very good question is why
why baptize infants why baptize infants
you know is you know what what is the
point of the Catholic Church saying well
we have to do this right away there's
there's some line of thinking that lies
behind that well I have an answer for
that and I believe it's a relevant
answer or were you about no no go go for
it uh I believe it was a genuine concern
for the Eternal well-being of children
that happened to die especially when
there was a much greater chance in that
day of children dying at young age the
mortality rate was not so good you know
so they wanted some kind of Blessed
assurance that this child is all right
but I believe they carried it too far
and there's really not a lot of
definitive information in the Bible
about what will happen if a child dies
prior to to being able to comprehend the
truths of God's word right but we do
know God is a just God right and a
merciful and good God and loving God and
he's not going to cut off from himself
eternally uh someone who's never had an
opportunity uh to receive the truth
necessarily and and that's a subject in
itself but I believe that was the reason
behind it because I do believe in infant
dedic
we do have yeah yeah absolutely we do
have a Biblical example of that with
Jesus uh 40 days after he was born
according to the law Mary had to come
and present herself after her days of
cleansing and purification and he was
dedicated at the and I'm sure he was
most likely circumcised as well and a
lot of Catholics will resort to that uh
example of circumcision MH as Pro proof
that baptism should be administered to
infants also but God expressly commanded
infants to be circumcised male Jewish
children yep but he never expressly
commanded infants in the New Covenant to
be baptized so there's no scriptural
directive in that particular area no
there's not
and of course Catholics will say well
the faith of the parents was sufficient
for the significance of the circumcision
ceremony to take place and yes I can see
that I can agree with that so they
translate that into a new covenant way
and say the faith of parents having the
child sprinkled is significant for all
of these things to take place but when
you balance it out with all the other
scriptures like Ephesians 3:17 says
Christ will dwell in Your Heart by faith
mhm so that child can't have faith right
that little infant cannot have faith but
as I was saying the substance is
supremely important infinitely more
important than the Shadow and water
baptism is the shadow but a life of a
person who is truly buried with Christ
who has been crucified with Christ dead
to self given their lives wholeheartedly
to him and been resurrected into a
Victorious lifestyle of of walking in
dominion over sin and satanic control of
life that's what's important not the
symbolic representation of that in
baptism which is important because it's
a god ordained ritual but it's not the
end of the story yeah it's it's
interesting that they're essentially
trying to solve a problem with this that
really is God's problem and God will
sort it out I like that point it's their
their motive is is fine and good I mean
ultimately it's like nobody wants to
think of a little child and say well if
we don't do something they're doomed to
hell and and you know for you know and
that that's that's disturbing to people
you know extremely it's it's a it's bad
marketing right um and and so modern day
terminology yeah to to kind of help God
out in that
situation they they have gone and taken
it this far whereas really if we trust
God God knows like you said God is a
just God God is a merciful god and we
don't have to help God out so to speak
when it comes to these kinds of problems
that we don't have you know the exact
answers to you know infant dies what
what happens well God is a just God he's
a merciful I trust God now two
scriptures or two thoughts I might bring
in before we leave this subject is first
1 Corinthians chapter 7 I believe verse
14 says the unbelieving husband is
Sanctified by the believing wife wife
therefore Your Children Are Holy and
they are not unclean I do believe that
the
children of parents or a parent who is
truly dedicated to God have a definite
Advantage spiritually I believe God
accepts the dedication of that child to
him and moves for them maybe in a more
profound way than would otherwise happen
but that doesn't ensure the Eternal
salvation of child right right and the
other thing I need to bring out is quite
often Catholics will resort to instances
in the New Testament where someone was
baptized and their household it actually
happened four times like Cornelius y the
Jailer after Paul uh prayed for him and
he was saved then he then the Bible went
on to explain what happened it said that
he and his whole household we're
baptized but in none of those four
instances is there a reference to an
infant or infants being baptized so you
can't base proof on that because they
could have been all adults or all of the
age where they fully comprehended what
was going on exactly that's that's the
whole thing to believe you have to be
able to comprehend you have to take
ownership right andant can't do that
it's God's business I guess to save us
and if we're trying to save our
children make that decision for them in
a way we're just kind of we are
bypassing all of the intellectual
psychological Pathways that God wants to
touch us and create that connection with
him in doing so so that's what I thought
about and essentially you're
substituting his right in place if
you're trying to be the means of
salvation for the child exactly which
not our prerogative in the least you
know because then what you start to do
away with is the whole concept of Free
Will exactly that's a good point that's
a big problem you know God cannot have
forced love and worship yeah otherwise
it's not genuine it's not love it's not
love and also you had a point there
where it says uh they get the gift of
eternal life that means that no matter
what you do you just go to heaven you
know if through the sprinkling like oh
even if the child doesn't choose god
well they have they have eternal life
they'll get there well there are other
Catholic doctrines that would come at it
from a different
direction or if you die in a state of
mortal sin they believe that you go to
hell so it actually contradicts each
other the two the the doctrines right
either that or I'm not completely sure
how they explain the disparity between
those two things but uh apparently
there's a belief that even if you're
baptized C that doesn't ensure that
you'll absolutely be saved no matter
what okay uh because you have to be a
practicing Catholic in order to in order
to qualify I I see it this way that
there's a professing church there's
2.6 billion people in the world that
profess to be Christian 2.6 billion half
of those are Roman Catholic about 1.3
billion are Catholic and predominantly
Roman Catholic then you have some other
uh actually there's 24 Catholic groups I
think it's 24 26 I explain and name them
in the book uh that are identified by
submission to the pope but they have
some traditions that are a little bit
different and cultures that they're
birthed in but anyway you have this huge
amount of people 2.6 billion who profess
faith in a historical Christ I did when
I was was a child I was part of the
quote unquote professing church because
I professed faith in a historical belief
but I didn't have a personal encounter
and Jesus said this is eternal life that
they might know me that they might know
you the only true God and Jesus Christ
whom thou has sent it's John chapter 17
this is eternal life he's talking to the
father he said that they might know you
and Jesus Christ whom you have s and so
it's not just knowing about him that's
important but knowing him personally and
I call that the possessing Church which
is right at the nucleus so that child
once again can't become a member of the
church because that child has no
personal knowledge or experiential
knowledge of God and I I should add
Satan will acknowledg that Jesus is the
son of God he's not going to be saved oh
wow yeah the devil believes there is one
God yeah exactly and trembles but that
doesn't mean he's saved I sure don't
believe in the ultimate reconciliation
of all things including the devil
exactly that would make all of life an
absurd dramatic put on play that has no
relevance yep that's right so
anyway have we covered that subject good
enough you think all right well let's go
to the next one which is really
important the priest stood okay now in
the Catholic church in all fairness I
much must mention that they do in the
catechism give priesthood status to all
believers but they uh they're not in the
same category as the ministerial
priesthood and I don't know when they
made that different differentiation it
may have been as a result of the
Reformation that they actually conceited
that much but growing up Catholic we
were never told we were also priests
right we never had that not did did you
hear that did you hear that when you had
your encounter with Catholicism and yet
first Peter 25 declares we are a holy
priesthood and 1 Peter 2:9 declares we
are a royal
priesthood and the word priest comes
from the Hebrew Cohen that basically
means one who has access into the
presence of God and any True Believer
over Hebrews Paul talked about how
through the blood of Jesus we have
access into the holy of
holies well you if you're already in the
holy of holies in a symbolic sense and
you have a relationship with God you
don't have to have a mediatorial priest
a goet for you to be forgiven of your
sins for you to receive communion for
you to make a departure from this world
where you receive the last rights so in
the Catholic Church the way you're bound
to the church is there has to be a
priest involved in baptism in communion
and there has to be a priest or a bishop
usually a bishop involved in
confirmation which is when you
supposedly receive the Seal of the Holy
Spirit and there has to be a priest
involved in confession which was the
most painful part of being a cathic did
you guys ever go to confession no cuz I
was a child so I never did did you I
didn't grow up in the Catholic church I
just know of it oh you just had Parents
my dad's side of the family oh okay so
none of you ever had that no no dark
experience so you did you did yeah oh
many many times yeah what what you do is
you go into a confessional usually I
think it was on Saturday night and you
would kneel before the priest and he
there's a a barrier between you and the
priest so you can't see his face but he
can see yours oh awkward oh very awkward
and and you say father forgive me for I
have sinned and the father you address
the priest yeah oh interesting not God
but the priest because the priest has
the power of absolution uh and Jesus
they
say gave that authority to the
priesthood when he breathed on the
disciples in the upper room and said
receive the Holy Spirit whosoever sins
you retain they are retained whosoever
sins you remit they are remitted unto
them and the teaching is that they were
the original
priests the the priesthood element
within the church but Jesus in the upper
room never said no one can be forgiven
now unless they come through you he said
whosoever sins you retain they are
retained or or if you remit their sins
they are remitted but he never said it
was a requirement to go through them and
and we probably need to camp on that
scripture I believe that whenever I lead
someone to Jesus I have witness to
mockers that
made a joke about yeah sure I'll receive
Jesus into my heart no intention of
repenting no intention of being right
and and when I would say now I can't
pray with you yet you got to get more
sincere you got to get more real with
God then in a sense I'm retaining their
sins because I'm acting as God's
representative but that's something any
believer with the Holy Spirit in his or
her life does yeah or and and I know
when I knelt down in the back of that
van and gave my heart to the Lord Jesus
I was battling all kinds of unbelief in
my
mind not really accepting the full
biblical worldview at the time but
struggling to believe and the man who
won me to the Lord kind of ushered me
into it because he had full faith it
could happen for me because it had
happened for him so he was praying for
me Father forgive him of his sin wash
him clean and then leading me in a
confession well in a sense he fulfilled
that role that Jesus talked about
whosoever sends you remit they are
remitted unto them because he brought me
before God prayerfully when we prayed
together to be saved but the dying Thief
didn't have that he went to Jesus
directly that's right and so people
don't have to have that go between yeah
the Bible also says that there's only
one mediator between God and man which
Jesus Christ First Timothy 2:5 that's
what I was looking at yeah do you want
to read it absolutely oh exactly how I
quoted yeah for there is one God and one
mediator between God and Men the man
Christ Jesus yeah perfect and then and
then to kind of go about the where
you're saying you have to call the
priest father um I don't remember the
exact reference but the the Bible says
you shall not call no man father except
your father there is one father true and
yet the Bible contradicts itself in that
area oh interesting uh yeah it is
interesting and I go into that deeply in
the book uh where Paul for
instance uh addressed one of the
churches he wrote and he said you have
many teachers but you do not have many
fathers for I've begotten you through
the gospel so he used that symbol in
that term ology concerning himself as a
spiritual father to them but he never
bore that title you never find in the
history of the church where Peter James
John or any of the rest of them had to
be addressed as Father Peter Father
James Father John Father Paul which
would exalt that position to more of a
mediatorial role like you have in in
confession
and and
see uh I thought that my sins could not
be forgiven unless I did that because
they teach that Absolution can only come
through the priests and at the end of
your confession session and you just
have to bury your heart and spill the
beans and tell it all and then usually
the priest will give you Penance to do
and that's part of the process he
absolves your sin first and I think this
probably was more defined after the
Reformation because a lot of
Protestants insisted that the Penance
was earning forgiveness but now they
teach that you actually are forgiven
first the priest absolves you but let me
insert this too I believe this whole
idea of a representative Elite
priesthood exclusive priesthood is a
throwback to the Old Testament and a lot
of what you find including things like
clerical clothing are a throwback to the
Old Testament where God did design
certain sacred garments for the priests
and God did pick out the ironic
priesthood The Offspring of Aaron who
were part of the tribe of Levi but again
it's like you said this is a shadow of
things to come and you know if we if we
really think about this especially
in light of uh Hebrews 4 where it says
for we do not have a high priest who
cannot sympathize with our weakness but
was in all points tempted as we are yet
without sin Let Us therefore come boldly
to the throne of grace that we may
obtain mercy and find Grace to help in
time of
need there's
this
inferiority that we find with man this
is just no substitute with what we can
get when we come to Christ and so it it
begs the question of
well why would I go to anybody else when
I can go to the best source you know
what's really almost amusing and yet sad
at the same time MH what's that during
the pandemic the pope released a
statement that because the churches were
closed Catholics could go direct God oh
my goodness I heard about
that when I read that I thought whoa you
finally get it it's like why can't it be
that way all the time right absolutely
absolutely but I would rush through
these prayers as a little catholic young
man I would go to the Altar and
desperate to be forgiven I didn't want
to go to hell and so I'd pray 10 our
fathers and five hail marries and three
glory be to gods and you know how kids
are I didn't a lot of times I don't
think I said it from my heart of hearts
I just rush through it our Father Was
art in heaven Hallowed be thy name thy
kingdom come th will be done on Earth as
it is in heaven give us this day our
daily bread and forgive us our deaths we
forgive our debors and lead us not into
temptation now I want to get out of here
as quick as I can right in his first
main recorded sermon Matthew 6 verse 7
Jesus refuted that practice he said use
not vain repetitions like the Heathen do
why because prayer is not
mechanical that way right it's
not uh it's not like a mantra a mantra
is repeated over and over and over again
because you're trying to coer some kind
of force and manipulate it to do your
bidding in Eastern religions in New Age
spirituality well we're doing the same
thing in Christianity if we think we
should pray the rosary or repeat prayers
over and over and over again in order to
convince God that were genuine in our
repentance that we just went through in
the the little booth where we confessed
our sins this is really strange but when
did Catholics start considering
themselves Christians or people of the
book because I used to hear it
from uh Catholics in my
family they would come down on you a
little bit because they say we are not
people of the book and that was when I
was younger then all of a sudden around
High School all of a sudden they were H
have you heard that well that's a I've
never heard it put exactly like that but
this is why Catholics can believe things
that are not found in the book that are
not found in the Bible because they
believe it's called the three-legged
stool of
Catholicism that there are three equal
legs equal in size and importance
holding up that uh seat of that stool
and one is sacred scripture well I agree
with that 100% the Bible yes but we're
we probably need to get back to that in
just a second but they also believe
sacred tradition is equally important
and also number three the magisterium
and the word magisterium is a reference
to three things it's the
instructions that are are a base a
foundation
for the Catholic belief system it's the
Bishops worldwide the ruling hierarchy
all the way up to the Pope that provide
that Foundation of Doctrine and it's the
act of teaching itself the magisterium
and
so if you find something in sacred
tradition that is promoted by the
magisterium it doesn't really matter if
is in sacred scripture or not because
they're all equally
authoritative and the way that justify
that and there's some logic behind it is
that the early church did not have the
Bible the Bible did not exist until the
end of the what the 4th Century yeah
just had the Old Testament basically the
writings of Moses the prophets however
they did have letters of Paul that were
distributed throughout the churches some
of them may have had it some of them may
have not had it uh they had
gospels uh that were certainly
distributed among them we don't know we
have no way of proving who did and who
did not have it so they depended a lot
on oral tradition yeah and so the
argument now is if it's not found in the
Bible that's okay because we have oral
tradition from the earlier leaders in
Christianity uh in Catholicism
concerning a certain ritual or tradition
or ceremony or belief and even so
my response to that would be this that
if a tradition or if a belief or if a
ritual or ceremony was valid and true
then by the end of the 4th century when
the Bible was
compiled and put together all of those
traditions and beliefs and practices
were contained within scripture at that
point and we don't need anything after
that to to veer from the scriptural
Revelation this is a timeline when
certain beliefs came into existence or
at least maybe they were points of
discussion uh among uh Catholics for
hundreds of years before they were
actually ratified or or officially
recognized as a Catholic belief but you
can see here uh only bishops and Priests
can conduct communion that was decided
in 3:25 ad all these are ad and in 364
ad uh they were very Fierce about
worshiping on Saturday that if you did
that uh you were
excommunicated and you had to worship on
Sunday and that of course was in line
with some laws that Constantine put into
motion then 398 prayers for the dead
which is commonplace now but didn't
happen until 300 years 350 years after
Jesus walked on the earth he never
taught doing
infant baptism regenerates that decision
was made 4:18 Mary's ever virgin State
553 confession to a priest that was
decided in the
600s that wasn't originally what the
disciples believed and taught uh 993 was
the first canonization of a saint which
is a very predominant belief in
Catholicism now praying to the Saints
and 1095 was
indulgences indul ences are things you
can do to get uh some of your penants
taken care of that will eleviate you
from years decades centuries in
purgatory and then 11:39 celibacy of
priests whoa you mean in the beginning
the Bible never demanded and even the uh
even the tradition of the elders did not
demand celibacy absolutely not Peter had
a wife that's right most of the other
apostles were married Paul did take upon
himself this commitment to celibacy but
he never said it was a
requirement all these priests that have
been coerced into believing they have to
live celibate lives to represent God in
this world most of them are really
genuine in being willing to make that
Supreme sacrifice but
unnecessarily they would have much more
Fuller lives sometimes if they had been
allowed to marry and have children in
fact in the early church Paul's writing
he said a bishop had to be the husband
of one wife and had to rule his
household well right and so Bishops were
not supposed to be celibate the exact
opposite but it's tradition and remember
the three legs of the stool it's not in
the Bible but it's in sacred tradition
and approved by the magisterium yes uh
12:15 clerical clothing was
required well I I can't see Jesus
telling his followers now you've got to
have a proper sacred kind of garment
that you wear so we're going to a local
seamstress and all of you are going to
wear robes that identify you as a an
apostle
1438 was when the doctrine of purgatory
was affirmed
officially and of course it had been a
thing of discussion for many centuries
but uh it actually was one of the
doctrines that caused a split between
the Roman Catholic church and the
Eastern portion of the Catholic church
and that was one thing they disagreed
wholeheartedly over then
1545 Traditions equal with the Bible the
Council of Trent was the council that
was held right after the Reformation
where they had to respond to many of the
doctrines that began to be promoted by
Martin Luther and others right and by
the way just because I respect Martin
Luther I don't respect everything he did
or believe because he still accepted
infant baptism right and he was very uh
much a persecutor of anabaptists who
believed in in being immersed in baptism
uh very serious persecution 1570
traditional Latin Mass 18 oh this is a
mindblower that even though the Maran
doctrines which are the doctrines about
Mary had been a point of discussion for
about a thousand years probably off and
on during the church and had also been
points of division they were not
officially declared as Dogma until just
about what a little over 150 years ago
what no it's not a little more a little
more than that the Immaculate Conception
which is the that Mary was conceived
without
sin that's exalting her to a status that
she had no right to be taken to because
all have sinned and come short of the
glory of God so which is right tradition
or the Bible I would just add real quick
that this made me think from the Bible
it's Mark 7 verse 8 and9 it says for
laying aside the Commandments of God ye
hold the tradition of men right as the
washing of pots and cups and many other
such like things things you do and he
said unto them full well ye reject the
Commandments of God that ye may keep
your own Traditions right and and that's
definitely an indictment against not
only Catholicism but many other
Protestant sexs that's right that hold
to things that are not biblical I do
believe the Bible is our standard and
that's what we've got to go through but
in
1854 the doctrine of the Immaculate
Conception was confirmed by a Papal
decree that was considered infallible a
lot of non-catholics don't realize
there's only been two times when an
infallible statement was made by a pope
Catholics do not believe everything a
Pope says is infallible it has to be
what's called ex cathedra which means
from the seat and symbolically that
means from the seed of Peter because
they believe the popes have inherited
authority over the church Church from
Peter and it's questionable whether or
not Peter was the head of the church
because James was head of the church in
Jerusalem and Paul perceived that James
and John and Peter were the pillars of
the church when he went and visited the
church in Jerusalem and pillars are
normally of equal height to hold up a
building so there's a possibility that
there was plurality of leadership in the
early church that Peter was in some kind
of Supreme pontiff and that's another
discussion in itself but papal
infallibility was declared in
1870 that's this idea that a pope can
speak infallibly that's handy and and
they made that effective back to
1854 uh so that they included popas I
9th in that right to be infallible in
your decree then uh
1950 another Pope pop the 12th I believe
it was yes uh made the infallible decree
that Mary was assumed up into heaven and
most Catholics believe that she actually
did die but she was brought back to life
and Body and Soul she was assumed back
up into heaven which is of course not
biblical at all and and she became and
this wasn't just an idea of birth in
1954 but it was solidified that she was
Queen of Heaven yeah the only people
that we understand have gone to heaven
besides Jesus Enoch Moses and Elijah
that the Bible specifically says have
gone they were translated right and then
the catechism was published in 1992 and
now it's available online which is a
wonderful resource and I've used it
quite a bit in the book where I went to
the Vatican website where the CATE
catechism is available and it's
irrefutable that the church believes in
certain things right but uh anyway
that's a huge overview of the evolution
of Catholicism and I have this posted on
our website our website just for this
project is two Catholics withth love.org
that's awesome and this is an article
there and this is shocking to a lot of
Catholics to realize hey I thought the
church believed these things for like
centuries Millennia and to realize that
they're relatively
recent doctrinal developments is a
little shocking to some people if I can
just insert you were mentioning your
website for the people at home who are
hearing this for the first time maybe
another really useful resource is um
truth about death.com and helltruth.com
if if the people at home want to check
it out because that kind of describes
why we are talking about these things
here you know regarding Mary Etc um
because you know if Catholics herit it's
for the first time like well give me
some scriptural evidence that Mary's not
in heaven right now those two websites
will be good resource mhm uh I'll tell
you what we need
to to revert back to is something we
didn't cover this like a a Lynch pin
it's a really important Doctrine and
that's
sainthood because when you're a Catholic
you pray to the Saints right yes you I I
had a grandmother that was a
wonderfully devoted beautiful person
that prayed the Rosary every day and
again it's repetitious prayer like we
already
covered but one thing I I want to cover
that I didn't mention is just suppose if
there's
1.3
billion Catholics in the world right
what if all of them prayed to Mar
every day that would be 1.3 billion
people communicating even if only
10% communicated and prayed to her in
one day to intercede for them before the
father then that would be 130 million
and if you break that down by dividing
it by
1,440 which are the number of minutes in
a day then every single minute over
990,000 people would be talking to Mary
how could she process that
number of conversations I tell people
it's not just theologically incorrect
it's logically incorrect right because
she's not God God has the capacity to
hear all of our prayers God is
omnipresent and omniscient and in order
to process over 990,000 conversations at
once a lot of those people are talking
about things in their environment oh
Mary my mother is sick here well you'd
have to be in over 990,000 locations at
once and being able to talk to over
990,000 people at one time omniscience
and omnipresence let me let me ask a
clar attribut only God has so I'm
wondering maybe I just misunderstand how
do they get around that because my
understanding is Catholics believe that
Mary is
divine well and that she's like a
co-mediator
with Christ so they have essentially
elevated her attributes to be above that
of a normal individual right so is that
how they kind of I most Catholics I
don't think would ever say Mary's part
of the godhead so to speak okay uh
but they do believe that she uh in in
strict Catholic doctrine that she lived
a sinless
life and that once she died she was also
assumed up in Heaven the Assumption and
when she got to Heaven she occupied the
role of being the Queen of Heaven and
that Revelation 12 the woman clothed
with the sun and the crown of 12 star is
a reference to Mary now some Catholics
will concede that it's a reference to
both Mary and uh the bride of Christ and
and that it can have multiple levels of
interpretation which really gets
complicated and I I wasn't going to try
and get into that but I do believe they
elevate to use your word Mary to a much
higher status she should be respected to
be so virtuous that God would choose you
for that role is absolutely amazing but
she's not ever virgin and in 553 we just
found out she was declared during one of
the councils to be ever virgin which
means before during and after the birth
of Jesus she remained a virgin for time
and Eternity that's not what the Bible
says right because the Bible said Joseph
after he heard from the angel did not
know her until after she had given birth
to her firstborn son which implied that
he did know her and that's a Biblical
term that means to have sexual relations
with your wife Adam knew Eve and they
had Cain and Abel and I go back to this
point I was trying to make earlier when
you have saints and you're praying to
Saints it's like but wait a minute the
Bible says in Matthew 28 that all
authority and power was given
to Jesus so why do you want to go to a
inferior or even a you know a subsource
other than Jesus to make your requests
why not go all the way to the top why
not go all the way to the best the one
who has all power and authority so it
it's it's in in a
way maybe not in people's minds
intentional but in a way I see it as
taking Jesus down a notch mhm right you
you put it in good words that's that's
that's exactly what happens even with
the the recent papal statement by
Francis that said you know uh you can
you know uh ask you can ask Jesus for
forgiveness of your sins you know during
during Co it's like yeah it's it seems
kind of elevating but at the same time
it's also Den ating to Christ it's like
well you know because you don't have a
priest I guess Jesus will
do right you know it's so it's it's
minimizing the authority and beauty and
power of Christ and it's also excluding
all the world outside of Catholicism now
there are some contributing statements
within Catholicism and it's in the
catechism that those who threw no fault
of their own do not do not accept Jesus
as their savior still have a potential
of being saved now and of course I'm
summarizing I'm not giving the exact
wording of the catechism but it tends to
imply to me that that means people in
cultures and religions where they're
never exposed to the message of
Christianity and God will somehow deal
with them differently but for the most
part like I would be considered a
heretic now because I don't acknowledge
the necessity of becoming Catholic and
submitting in to the authority of the
Pope and so forth in order to be a part
of the church but I believe I am part of
the mystical Body of Christ if you want
to put it that way and I believe you are
too that we are all born again into the
body of Christ uh if we've received him
into our
lives but uh anyway uh the whole idea of
saints a lot of is predicated on the
Book of
Revelation
where and that gets really complicated
maybe I should just say get the book and
and read through that part because the
Saints have golden bowls full or the um
the living creatures have golden bowls
full of the prayers of the saint that
they bring to God sure right and chorus
in order to substantiate the whole idea
of going through through the Saints then
you you make it exclusive where only
those that have lived very Pious lives
and have worked two Miracles you have to
work at least two Miracles after death
through the petitions of those who
believe in you to be canonized as a
saint a practice that was never a part
of early Christianity the first
canonized Saint didn't happen until 993
ad but but when you pray to the Saints
they're supposed to pray in your behalf
uh a Catholic differentiates between
prayer and worship they don't feel that
they worship the Saints or worship Mary
they feel they pray to them but at the
same time I I would consider it a
worshipfulness that is excessive and
Beyond what God W would intend for a
true Christian and I've got a couple of
scriptures here that show that sainthood
if you will is applied to all of us yeah
every believer yeah uh in fact one time
I was uh speaking at a Minister's
meeting and I brought out these
scriptures like this one Paul an apostle
of Jesus Christ by the will of God to
the Saints who are in Ephesus and
faithful in Christ Jesus Paul an apostle
of Christ Jesus by the will of God and
Timothy our brother to the Saints and
faithful brothers in Christ at colos uh
all the church members were considered
Saints how could that be I thought a
saint was this person that achieves this
High degree of piety and commitment and
withdrawal from the world and becomes an
amazing connection to God well every
Born Again believer is Sanctified if
you're truly born again you're
Sanctified and to be Sanctified is the
qualification of being a saint
and the word Sanctified has three
meanings it means to be cleansed of the
defilement of sin to be separated from
the world and to be consecrated to God a
Triune meaning and anyone who is
genuinely saved is cleansed from the
defilement of sin separated from the
world and consecrated to God and they
become a saint anyway I was in this
Minister's meeting and I was ministering
along these lines that we should not
only be Saints because we've inherited
the title but in lifestyle also and I
said you need to get used to applying
this term to yourself so everybody turn
around and introduce yourself to the
person next to you is St so and so I
didn't know that the guy on the front
row was Peter and sitting next to
him yeah sitting next to him was a guy
named Thomas and he shook hands uh the
first guy shook hands with the other one
and said hi I'm St Peter and I've got
the keys to the Gate of Heaven and the
other guy said hi I'm St Thomas and I
doubt
that that's hilarious but anyway um yeah
you make a good point because if you
know the historical background with the
Ephesian Church Paul makes a point
especially with them like you know you
were once in
darkness but now you are light in the
Lord you know and
so when he recounts their history which
you can read a little bit about in Acts
and other places they weren't what we
would think of as Saints right they were
not the always the most upstanding
people in society they had colorful past
and background but they had been
converted right and that's what you're
getting at is you know we can be
considered Saints when God gets a hold
of our life there's over a thousand
names and titles that belong to the
children of God with the redeemed the
church the bride of Christ the anointed
Saints and Heirs of righteousness so so
forth but just because we bear a title
doesn't mean we're fully walking in the
reality of it and there's a lot of even
for instance newborn Christians that are
still struggling with their past that
are truly Saints in a potential sins but
they haven't sure gone through death to
self enough for it really to be
manifested in their lifestyle to the
degree it needs to right and so we
should have as our goal walking in a
saintly way through life sure uh but we
inherit the status first and then it
becomes a living reality as we walk it
out just like I could hold an acorn in
my hand and say hey look at this oak
tree the oak tree yeah it's not an oak
tree no man that's an acorn yeah but
hidden in the heart hidden in the heart
of the acorn is the life of an oak tree
and if you bury this in the ground if it
dies sure it'll erupt into what Destiny
is and of course that's the reason we
have to be buried with Christ and die to
self and and give our all to
himh
so uh what about confirmation I was
confirmed H as an 11 12 year old I think
it was 11 when it happened what's
confirmation again is that way you went
through the whole communion class and
then no no it's a separate Sacrament
okay it's when you supposedly receed the
Seal of the Holy Holy
Spirit but Paul indicated you receive
the soul of seal of the Holy Spirit at
Salvation and we see also uh that Jesus
specifically received it after he was
baptized and also you were pointing out
earlier um when Peter was preaching and
what was it like 3,000 or so got
baptized they receiv received the Holy
Spirit they receiv received the gift of
the holy spirit because it's a public
statement of saying I as a person who
understands the decision that I'm making
as an adult or you know we have younger
children in our church being baptized
but they are old enough where they go
through the Bible studies and understand
I want to follow Jesus right and so you
see in the Bible they were old enough
they wanted to make a conscious decision
to follow Jesus therefore they went
through the act of a public statement of
baptism through immersion where they say
I want to die to my old self and have
Jesus come in my heart and the Holy
Spirit is received right and and that's
scripturally correct to see it that way
and then after I was saved I had
encounters with the Holy Spirit later on
that were very very profound but I
didn't have any kind of encounter I
didn't have any baptism in the Holy
Spirit when the bishop laid hands on me
and I kissed his ring and he slapped me
as a sign of suffering for Christ I
thought later on I thought if that's all
the suffering I have to go through to be
a Christian slap me right on you know
but uh I don't think they do that
anymore but back in the day when I
receiv received confirmation uh that was
supposed to be uh the turning point in
my life but I didn't become any
different kind of person in fact from
that point forward my life started
falling apart and if ID really had a
baptism with the Holy Spirit then it
should have been different Al together
different Al together but again a lot of
the these things stem not necessarily
this Doctrine but a lot of what we've
talked about stem from Old Testament
practices where Jews had to go through
the priests had to go through the
Spiritual Authority in order to get to
God and so if they lock it into that
system where the bishop has to come
yearly for you to receive this encounter
or you have to go to the priest to be
forgiven of your sin or you have to have
a priest in order to have an infant B
then uh then you're tying people into
the system Y and and then it becomes uh
a
very exclusive thing yep and I suppose
if people want more information you have
a book that goes over all this in detail
much more detailed than we have probably
covered today so it is once again the
beliefs of the Catholic Church 25
questions comparing Doctrine practices
and Traditions to scripture and where do
they get this book if they're interested
well they can go a couple of places
different places they can go to our
website that's associated with this
project which is to Catholics withth
love okay.org we also have another
website that primarily focuses on
comparative religion subjects between
biblical Christianity and Far Eastern
religions and it's become a very popular
website called the true
light.net okay the true light.net and
we've had over four million people hit
that website that's good worldwide and
we've had people from over a hundred
Nations download my personal testimony
story it's called the highest Adventure
encountering God it's a booklet
available in 12 languages wow on the
true light.net okay so some people might
be interested in going there and the
beliefs of the Catholic Church book is
also available on that website okay it's
also available on shev ministries.org
and then there's this little company
called Amazon I think I've heard of them
yeah yeah so Amazon they they offer to
and it will be available as an ebook
Okay that my question very soon in fact
uh probably within a week of the time
we've we've recorded this program so by
the time you show it it's probably on
Amazon as an ebook all right you can get
it on Kindle well thank you so much for
joining us and having this
discussion and we of course hope and
pray that it's productive for those who
are seeking for truth and wisdom and in
these things and so well thank you st
Keith for having
me yeah and say Bri we uh it's important
that we know what we believe it's
important that we know our Bibles and
it's important that we know Jesus so
with that we will uh address our viewers
thank you again for joining us we hope
this discussion has been profitable to
you make sure you share it with somebody
who might need to hear something like
this and so there's a share button on
this video there's also a like button so
you can like it that of course helps the
video get out into the algorithm of
YouTube there's also a subscribe button
if you found this content impactful and
you want to see more content coming out
make sure you do that as well if you're
looking to support a Ministry like this
you can go to LLS .tv /give that link
will be in the description below or one
similar to it so that you can help
donate and keep programs like this on
the year and keep going there's other
ways to support us too there's patreon
and of course we have a separate company
that we um Print T-Shirts out of called
lightwear so those links will also be in
the description below thank you for
joining us and make sure you say hi to
Aubrey our new team member and we will
see you next time on LED live take
care
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to show
kindness to the
[Music]
world every day is an opportunity to do
something that lets someone know you're
thinking of
them every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in
[Music]
return
every day is an opportunity to notice
someone in need and to go out of your
way to help
them every day is an
opportunity to do one small
thing to show someone you
care to make the world a better
place
[Music]
oh